Eric if you had to narrow it down to
precisely one thing like obviously it's
more than one thing but if you just had
to say like what one thing more than
anything else seems to be the primary
mechanism of muscle hypertrophy what
what would you say yeah so that would
bring me back to um there's a few like
pretty in-depth reviews about the
mechanism of muscle hypertrophy usually
they narrow it down to Mechanical
tension muscle damage and metabolic
stress and I actually would uh you know
I I would say that mechanical tension
being the first one there that that's
the one I would go with
um if I had to pick one yeah so I I
agree with you I I think that's a great
answer
and with that context a paper was
recently published with a very
provocative title effective resistance
training mainly depends on mechanical
activation of fast twitch fibers and so
uh what I want to do in this segment is
address
partially is that true but more so
does does the paper bearing that title
present us with adequate evidence to
believe that it's true yeah um and so
the short version just here up top not
trying to leave people in suspense is uh
no I I don't think we should put much
stock if any in this particular paper
and the reason I want to talk about this
the reason I'm doing this segment is
I've started seeing this paper going
around I think it was published about a
month ago uh first time it came across
any of my timelines was maybe like two
weeks ago and within the last week I've
seen more and more people sharing it
talking about it discussing it uh and
it's not it's not big yet it's kind of
like simmering below the surface but I'm
concerned that it will kind of reach a
critical mass and uh like a lot of folks
will become aware of it and uncritically
accept its findings as true uh and it's
like a band that plays the cooler bars
in town and when they have a gig a lot
of people show up but like they don't
have a huge record deal yet correct yeah
yeah so
um yeah basically I
I think that this is a a
paper with findings built on incredibly
shaky foundations that I don't think we
should put much stock in so I I want to
do this segment just to just to head
that off essentially cool
um and just as a general note
if you have shared this paper uh
perhaps uncritically
um I this isn't a call out segment I
don't I don't begrudge you for doing
that I certainly don't think less of you
for doing that
um because like the the title of the
paper and its purported findings do seem
to track well with things we already
know mechanical tension seems to be very
important for hypertrophy so people's a
paper saying mechanical activation of
fast twitch fiber seem to be the primary
driving factor of hypertrophy that seems
to comport well with what we already
know and you know if things already
confirm what you know or strongly
suspect to be true you might be a little
bit less likely to look into it deeply
um and also like I I do think that
there's just sort of a general Zeitgeist
around trying to find like a grand
unified theory of hypertrophy and that
sort of thing is just kind of like
intrinsically appealing to people and
the other reason I don't begrudge folks
for taking this paper uncritically is
this study and also kind of the study
it's built upon
are very math heavy like extremely math
heavy and
so like I I'm the type of sick [ __ ]
who's willing to look at that and be
like oh okay let's let's put all of
these equations in a spreadsheet kind of
work through them see what's going on
here but like I totally get that if
someone either doesn't have a strong
math background or is just like a normal
person with plenty of things to do in in
a day you just see more than like three
Greek letters in a block of text and say
nope [ __ ] it like I'm I'm just gonna
trust that the authors did everything
right because it's not worth my time to
get into this
um so yeah uh if I can make a quick
comment before you dig into the details
here I don't mean to grab the steering
oh yeah but go for it I really like the
way that you it was a very subtle thing
but the way that you uh kind of alluded
to confirmation bias there where where
basically it seems to comport well with
kind of how you generally view things
and so you just kind of uncritically say
yeah that that works that makes sense
and you roll with it I think a lot of
people believe deep down that like
confirmation bias is a malicious Act of
cherry picking and that like when
someone is committing confirmation bias
or or expressing it they're like digging
in and saying how can I prove myself
right despite contradictory evidence but
I think the more
um uh the more damaging version of
confirmation bias is just that thing
where you say it's not that I'm like
maliciously cherry picking but like
because this comports with what I would
expect I'm simply not going to
scrutinize it with that same level of
intensity oh yeah for sure and I mean I
100 do that as well it's a natural
that's why it's a term it's a time
saving mechanism yeah yeah like if a
paper comes across the journal sweep and
it's like hey hey it's a high low
training versus low low training and
we're looking to see which one has a
larger effect on 1rm strength oh the
high load training did cool like I'm not
going to look into that paper in detail
and say like yeah does this finding hold
up because it's like well I I know or at
least so strongly suspect that to be
true I don't care that much about the
details like I'm just gonna put another
tally in the Hilo training is better
column you know and there's a
considerable degree of redundancy in our
our field oh yeah and I I kind of
chuckled because I was thinking about
like you know a paper comes across and
says yeah creatine made people a little
stronger am I really gonna be like well
I need to email the author because I
can't find supplementary table number
three correct yeah it's just you you
file it away and say yeah that makes
sense correct yeah so to be clear what
I'm arguing here is not that mechanical
activation of fast twitch fibers aren't
a predictive factor for hypertrophy what
I'm arguing is this is not the study you
you should rely on to make that point
yeah all right so
um at this point if you're if you're
watching on YouTube we can just flash
the or we can just put the the abstract
up here because I think that's the part
of the study that most people have
actually read at this point and for
people listening I'm just going to read
the abstract just so we can all kind of
get our feet wet and understand the
sorts of claims that this paper is
making so the abstract says this study
conducted a secondary survey based on
the hypothesis that quote total
mechanical activation of fast twitch
fibers and the muscles determines the
effects of muscle hypertrophy close
quote with resistance training of the
knee extensor muscles as the Target
because of its importance in preventing
sarcopenia using a mathematical model
that estimates the mechanical activation
of each muscle fiber parentheses fast
twitch and slow twitch fibers close
parentheses during exercise which was
developed in a previous study we
estimated the total mechanical
activation of fast twitch fibers and 30
training programs described in 23
selected previous studies on leg
extension exercise programs and their
muscle hypertrophy effect with the
estimated value and other factors of the
training effect described in previous
studies training volume Etc as
explanatory variables and muscle
hypertrophy effect as an objective
variable We performed multiple
regression analysis the results revealed
that the training effect was related to
Total mechanical activation of the fast
twitch fibers training load and number
of sets with the beta coefficients being
positive for mechanical activation of
fast twitch fibers and training load and
negative four number of sets
going on the total mechanical activation
of fast twitch fibers was the strongest
determinant of the muscle hypertrophy
effect that one quote right there as an
aside that one quote right there I think
is the thing people are are really
focusing on going on in addition we
predicted the relationship between the
level of the training effect of leg
extension exercise and program variables
this study is the first to demonstrate
quote the relationship between total
mechanical activation of fast twitch
fibers and muscle hypertrophy effect
close quote in the field of muscle
physiology and the first to elucidate
the association between the program
variables and the training effect so
just in layman's terms to break all of
that down what they did for this study
is they went through the literature they
didn't do a truly systematic literature
search essentially they they developed
some key terms and just just looked at
the hundred like the first hundred
studies with those key terms in them and
looked for the ones uh where there was a
longitudinal knee extension training
intervention with you know all of the
information they would need to apply
their model to it and they identified 23
such studies and the hundred results
they screened with 30 different training
protocols that assessed hypertrophy over
time once they found those studies and
those protocols they used a mathematical
model that they'd previously developed
to estimate total fast twitch fiber
activation during each protocol so
that's like that's an integrated effect
sort of area under the curve and then
from there they performed multiple
regression analysis to see which
training variables were predictive of
hypertrophy responses and what they
found is that the strongest best
predictor was total mechanical
activation of fast twitch fibers which
was positively associated with
hypertrophy and then the other thing
people seem to be pulling out of this I
think erroneously is that in their
multiple regression model there was a
negative beta coefficient for
um
for number of sets like total training
volume and people are using this to
argue like ooh like
everyone's wrong about the effect of
training volume on muscle growth there's
a negative beta coefficient here if you
do more volume that leads to less growth
but with multiple regression that that's
basically saying when you hold like when
accounting for the other variables in
the model this seems to be negatively
predictive and so essentially total
activation of fast twitch fibers is
positively associated with training
volume because it's like a cumulative
metric like an area under the Curve
Metric and so essentially that negative
beta coefficient is telling you that the
additive effect of each additional set
is smaller and smaller so just to make
that clear
um but yeah anyway that's that's kind of
the the Layman
that was a pretty poor layman's terms
breakdown but that's that's sort of the
the grand
concise overview yeah that's that's the
general overview of the study
and like I said I think the part that
jumped out to most people when they were
were reading that abstract was just kind
of the core kind of flashy finding there
in the abstract that total mechanical
activation of fast twitch muscle fibers
was predictive of hypertrophy the thing
that jumped out at me was uh
this sentence specifically using the
mathematical model that estimates the
mechanical activation of each muscle
fiber uh fast twitch and slow twitch
which was developed in in a previous
study so you know they weren't using
studies that had measured mechanical
activation of fast twitch muscle fibers
they were using uh a set of equations to
estimate that variable and so that was
the thing that jumped out at me uh and
the reason that jumped out at me is that
I didn't think we could do that
particularly well
um for for a couple of reasons one is
that there aren't that many Labs that
can actually measure that variable so if
you're interested in looking at the
actual like Recruitment and activation
patterns of different fiber types you
need a very particular EMG setup like
high density EMG that you can use to
decompose the signals and look at
individual fibers which you can then
split out by fiber type and there aren't
that many Labs that can do that that
type of research and I also think we're
kind of a long way from being able to do
that type of research with Dynamic
exercise like you know eccentric and
concentric knee extensions because for
high density EMG to get good signals
that you can decompose and look at the
individual fibers I think you need to do
isometric exercise because you know the
electrodes are on the skin and as the
the muscle contracts like the position
of the individual fibers relative to the
skin moves a little bit
and so I think you have to do this only
with isometric exercise so like that
part jumped out at me when I was reading
the abstract because I was like oh like
that's that's actually incredibly cool
like if there's a a high quality
validated uh equation or set of
equations to be able to predict
um like fast twitch and slow twitch
fiber activation in Dynamic exercise
with any any reasonable degree of
granularity that's
if that exists like that's that's a
pretty big deal uh and I didn't know
that existed so I I was like okay let's
look at the paper that they're saying uh
like validated that equation uh and so
to be clear
the the main paper I'm talking about
here effective resistance training
mainly depends on mechanical activation
of fast twitch fiber like that paper
its findings rest solely on the
validation study at citing like because
their their data like their their
predicted data for fast twitch fiber
activation for their main study
like that all came from the equations
developed in the prior study they're
citing to which if you want to check all
of this out in the main paper it's
citation 20 you can pull it up for
yourself and so if the the paper they're
citing to if it shows good strong data
to say like hey based on these variables
we can predict fast twitch fiber
activation very well then this might be
a good reliable robust finding if we
look at this validation study and it
doesn't seem to predict fast twitch
fiber activation particularly well or
heaven forbid if that's not even what
that study was doing in the first place
uh you know maybe we're dealing with a
house built on Sand here uh so I pulled
up the validation study the title was
proposal and validation of mathematical
model for resistance training and before
I get into this uh Eric
can you just describe to me how
validation studies tend to work in our
field
yeah so you know there's different types
of validity and therefore different
types of validation studies
um I didn't do any equation validation
in my PhD we would normally do
validation for instruments and that's
pretty straightforward you're pretty
much comparing to a gold standard
Criterion measurement and saying hey how
close did we get
um but generally speaking when you're
trying to develop and validate an
equation you need to recruit a sample
that's theoretically representative of
the population you're trying to validate
this in and derive the predictive
equation so you measure some data you
measure the outcome of Interest
basically say okay which of these
predictors and in what combination
do we get a good you know predictive
equation that that describes or explains
the variance in that outcome right
and that's the first step but if you
bring in any sample of people you you
can get an equation correct like things
vary and therefore you will get an
equation if you really want one yes the
point where it becomes validation is
when you say you know what
the equation we got from these
individuals also works with other
samples of individuals from this
population yes so transferring those
values because you will get values
transferring those to other samples
effectively and reliably is where the
magic happens right so the the two
things there is one uh
you want you want to recruit a
representative sample and you also
generally want it to be a large enough
sample that you can have
reasonable reasonable confidence that
the equations you derive the findings
you get will generalize to the broader
population yeah and two
um generally and I think always you want
to actually measure the thing you're
trying to predict yeah so for example if
you were trying to make a new body
composition equation you might have
people do a four compartment body
composition assessment and then look at
their maybe age lean mass sex maybe
activity level just whatever like any
number of things and then develop a set
of equations to see okay we've measured
their body composition we have this
other data can we use these other
variables to predict body comp which
which we measured and then you get
another sample in and say hey we measure
their body composition we collect this
other data does that set of equations
that I previously developed still
predict body comp pretty well in this
other sample okay so the but quite
notably there
you assessed body comp in both of those
samples right if that's the thing you're
trying to validate for so
when diving into this validation study
the first thing that jumped out of me is
there were only six subjects which
I mean maybe those are six subjects that
are incredibly representative of the
target population they were drawn from
and generally I'm not the the type of
person to uh like be such a nitpicker
about sample size but for for validation
studies like
you need more than that and that's six
subjects total that's not one population
of six subjects and then see if
equations hold up in another population
of six subjects it's just six subjects
which uh not a ton uh and then
uh the second thing that jumped out at
me and this is really the kicker they
didn't measure fast twitch fiber
activation in this study like they just
didn't uh like you can read the methods
for yourself this the both of these
studies I'm talking about full text is
free they'll be linked in the show notes
you can read this for yourself at no
point in the study did they actually
measure fast twitch fiber activation
they didn't even measure EMG like
nothing that was even like a proxy for
muscle activation at all and so if you
work your way through the study
ultimately what they were doing is they
were using quite a lot of complex math
to predict how many reps people would be
able to complete during sets to failure
with different loads at different
contraction velocities and with
different rest intervals and
how this worked is essentially they had
like 17 protocols they put these people
through and they looked to see whether
like they developed a set of equations
to predict uh how many reps they'd be
able to complete on subsequent sets of
like five set protocols with six of the
17 protocols and then they look to see
whether the equations they developed
from those six protocols could predict
uh reps to failure with the other 11
protocols with slightly different mixes
of training variables which you know is
a completely reasonable way to do a
validation study but again generally
you'd probably want more than six
subjects
um
but like the important thing here is
this was not a validation study to see
if they could predict fast twitch fiber
activation it just wasn't
um what it was is there was one
particular equation in the set like in
the large set of equations they used
that contained assumptions about fast
and slow twitch fiber activation in
total fiber activation
um and it seems to be what they're doing
is saying well assumptions about fiber
activation were built in or kind of
baked into the equations we used the
equations we used seem to do a decent
job of predicting reps to failure
performance therefore all of the
assumptions baked into our equations
must therefore be true which
I don't know what else to say other than
that's not how that works yeah uh so uh
how a validation study for this might
look is that you could measure fast
twitch fiber activation during training
protocols in a group of subjects then
you develop a set of regression
equations based on get on data gathered
during those protocols to see if there's
a mix of variables that were predictive
of actual fast twitch fiber activation
then you put a new group of subjects
through those same training protocols uh
measure fiber act measure fast twitch
fiber activation as that new group of
subjects goes through these protocols
and then see whether the equations you
developed on that first population did
actually predict fast twitch fiber
activation in the second population
that's that's how you might do a
validation study to predict fast twitch
fiber activation from various like
training program characteristics that's
not what they did in their in their
validation study to be clear like to put
this in no uncertain terms the
validation study they're citing was not
a validation study for predicting fast
twitch fiber activation it simply it
simply wasn't and I I don't know how
else to put it yeah so essentially the
the main paper I'm talking about here is
it's it's a house built on the sand like
the the data going into their model for
prediction of fast twitch fiber
activation from those 23 studies and 30
training protocols there is no reason to
suspect that they were accurately
predicting fast twitch fiber activation
in those 23 studies no reason whatsoever
yeah
um
and so uh
yeah I mean that's that's the bulk of my
critique uh it's this isn't a study to
to put
like any stock end whatsoever and I'll
also note just in Broad Strokes like if
you if you didn't want to get into all
of the nerd [ __ ] of actually going to
look at their supposed validation study
for this and and digging into it uh you
could just look at the text of the study
itself so there's uh and if you're
watching on YouTube we can we can Flash
an image up here
um like there's a figure just showing
the the bivariate relationship between
their predicted mechanical activation of
fast twitch fibers and increase in
muscle size and like
you can look at it for yourself there's
not much of a relationship there like in
in the two protocols with the lowest
predicted mechanical activation of fast
twitch fibers not much hypertrophy
occurred and then there's one like one
study where like in absurd amount of
hypertrophy occurred that did also have
a high predicted amount of mechanical
activation of fast twitch fibers but
beyond those like three data points
everything from like the the y-axis or
the x-axis here goes from like 200 to
1600 everything from like 500 to 1600
looks basically the same like you could
just draw a straight line through that
data like just just pure visual
inspection tells you that there's not a
particularly strong relationship there
um
and if that's not enough going an
additional step deeper like the actual
model they developed in their supposed
validation study also just conflicts
with experimental evidence in this area
so
I got another question for you Eric so
yeah let's hear it you're a bodybuilder
uh two sport professional bodybuilder
yeah I'm a bodybuilder but I more think
of myself as a classic bodybuilder yeah
that's fair but I mean you you are a pro
at both correct the Bo Jackson a
bodybuilding many people are saying so
you know you know a thing or two about
building muscle and how you might
personally train to go about trying to
build muscle
and so you know let's say you wanted to
do some low load training for for any
number of purposes maybe you just want a
bit of masochistic fun maybe you're
trying to train around or through an
injury and you can't load a joint
particularly heavy and and you have two
options on the table you can either do
three all-out sets of 30 reps with a
load that you can only do 30 reps with
so so three sets to failure 30 reps per
set really getting after it or
alternately you could do nine sets of 10
reps with the same load a load that you
could do 30 reps with with nice long
rest intervals per Set uh and you know
you're equating the number of reps
you're doing it's 90 reps regardless of
the same load yeah with the same load
but it's three sets of 30 versus nine
sets of ten which one of those protocols
do you think you would derive a a
stronger growth stimulus from
I would expect the the three sets of 30.
yeah so I I would as well but again like
so this is something else we've talked
about on the podcast before like
when you're evaluating research are are
you signing actually maybe we maybe this
was a mass audio thing uh the thing
about eating fruit and whether that
makes you gain or lose 20 pounds or
whatever yeah uh anyways
um yeah so we we've talked about like
are you willing to take the results of
the study literally or not and if you're
willing to cite this paper and say hey
this is this is proof that uh mechanical
activation of fast twitch fibers is the
predictive factor of hypertrophy
if you're willing to do that and you're
you're signing on to this this is a
literal finding that we should take
seriously then you are implicitly
signing on to the study they're citing
for predicting fast twitch fiber
activation and when you look into that
that that would lead you to the point
where you would then therefore have to
argue that the nine sets of ten would be
a better hypertrophy stimulus which I
don't think many people would want to
like that I don't I don't think many
people are going to carry water for that
idea so and if I could just
contextualize that you mentioned the
fruit study basically there's a study
indicating there's two different groups
one group they're like hey try to eat
like a little more fruit and that's the
entire intervention yeah the other group
they're like hey have a little bit less
fruit and that's the entire intervention
and they ended up having like a 30 pound
Gap in weight change over like the six
month trial and my my argument was like
no one actually believes this yeah like
no one literally believes that to be
true yeah
so the the model that they developed in
their previous study with assumptions
about fast and slow twitch fiber
activations baked in their model
essentially assumes that fast twitch
fiber activation progressively decreases
due to fatigue which is probably true
like that is potentially and and maybe
even likely one of the reasons why uh
training with really short rest
intervals is maybe less productive for
hypertrophy than slightly longer rest
intervals as fatigue accumulates uh
fiber recruitment might drop off a
little bit
um their model also assumes that fast
twitch fiber activation doesn't increase
as the set progresses and again if
you're watching on YouTube there's a
figure from that validation study that
we can put up here this is figure three
uh A and B so it shows uh predicted uh
fast twitch and total fiber activation
during sets with 80 percent of one RM
and like it
like if you're watching this on YouTube
you can just look at it if you're
listening I can describe it to you uh
essentially it's showing predicted fast
twitch fiber activation in a over nine
reps and it is not changing rep to rep
to rep uh like it's a a solid a solid
line and the predicted fast twitch fiber
activation for each rep is the same as
the one before it and then B is the same
prediction but for the last set of an
exercise and uh yeah it's the same like
the predicted fast twitch fiber
activation is the exact same for every
single rep so it's
and that does conflict with uh
experimental evidence and also like the
best theoretical models we have of fiber
activation like it seems that as you get
closer to failure
um you recruit more of your higher
threshold motor units and uh like the
the uh
the the depolarization rate of your
highest threshold motor units increase
as you get closer to failure so that one
like their their model does seem to
conflict in that way with experimental
results
um
and their model essentially predicts
that the total uh like integrated area
under that curve is what is predictive
of hypertrophy and so essentially what
that signs you up to believe is that the
earliest reps in a set are just as
stimulating for hypertrophy as the later
reps in a set there's there's no
difference between those reps and the
activation of fast twitch fibers does
decrease as fatigue accumulates so you
don't want to go to failure and you
don't want to have short rest intervals
you want to stay a long way from failure
and have nice long rest intervals so you
don't accumulate fatigue and fast twitch
fiber activation stays high so if you
take this model seriously
like you're you would be saying nine
sets of ten at a 30 RM load is better
for hypertrophy than three sets of 30.
at a 30 RM load like that's like with 30
sets of three be even better potentially
so which again like I I don't think
anyone would actually argue for in the
real world but if if you're taking this
model seriously you have to be willing
to argue for that because that is a
logical implication of this model that
you're putting your weight behind yeah
um and so like that
also just like conflicts with
longitudinal hypertrophy research we
have so there was a paper by uh
lasavikius and colleagues in 2019 called
muscle failure promotes greater muscle
hypertrophy and low load but not high
load training and it was essentially a
study looking at at this scenario we're
describing so there were four conditions
here uh two high load two low load
conditions uh two of the conditions
subjects just performed three sets to
failure and in the other two so a high
load to failure condition a low load to
failure condition and then the other two
groups one high load one low load group
they did five sets with sixty percent of
the number of reps as the to failure
condition so uh essentially if you
completed 80 total reps across three
sets to failure and the low load
condition you would do uh five sets of
16 to equate the total number of reps so
it would be sixty percent the number of
reps per set for sixty percent more sets
so it all works out or
66 whatever like you you get what I'm
saying yeah uh or if someone did like
three sets of ten to failure in the high
load condition 30 total Reps for the
non-failure condition they would do five
sets of six reps to equate uh and so in
that study if if you were taking this
model literally and seriously you would
predict that the non-failure conditions
would cause at least as much hypertrophy
as the failure conditions if not more uh
and what they did in fact actually find
and if you're watching this on YouTube
we'll we'll put the results up on the
screen the two high load conditions
caused the same amount of hypertrophy so
the failure and non-failure condition
both LED to similar muscle growth and
then for the low load conditions the
failure condition led to considerably
more muscle growth than than the
non-failure condition so again if you
were taking this model seriously that
would this finding would fully conflict
with that model it's should be better to
do the low load training further from
failure so you don't accumulate as much
fatigue so fast twitch fiber activation
stays higher that is not what we see in
the actual experimental research so
just to recap the equations used in this
study to predict fast twitch fiber
activation haven't actually been
validated for predicting fast twitch
fiber activation and this whole segment
could could have just ended there like
that that wouldn't be any fun though
yeah that's that's enough to completely
obsolete the the main study I'm talking
about here
um but then also like The Logical
implications of the model that this is
all based on uh conflict with
experimental data and also just real
world experience like no no one would
actually train in the way that it is
suggested you should train if you take
this model seriously yeah uh so that's
all I've got and apologies if this
segment came across as too mean or too
harsh but like I said this this study
seems to be starting to gain a foothold
and
I just think it would be a real shame if
if it kind of entered the public
Zeitgeist and folks were being like Oh
yeah like this is this is really solid
stuff we know what is predict like we
know what's causing hypertrophy based on
this study because
you just shouldn't you shouldn't draw
that conclusion from it like it's it's
not uh
like not to be too harsh but like it's
it's just not good work yeah
um and so yeah like I
you know I think there's value in
debunking misinformation that's already
out there and I also think there's value
in debunking misinformation before it
starts to take off and that's that's
what I'm trying to do here yeah no I
think you did a great job and I I think
it's it's really important when you're
looking at a new study
um and you have access to the full text
just a couple quick things to prevent
from being led totally astray by some of
the chatter on social media
look at what actually got measured uh
look at not just the direction of
results but the actual magnitude and
then ask yourself in a very literal way
do I believe that yeah and like I I know
it sounds overly simplistic but if you
just you know use that as your just
entry point into a paper as like the
basic bare minimum of interpretation
it'll actually get you pretty far yeah
and that was one of the things I I don't
know if I misspoke when explaining the
the intervention with that fruit paper
but one group uh just had a tiny
increase in Fruit intake the other had a
tiny decrease and the researchers were
saying oh what happens to body weight
Greg you are familiar with fruit right I
am yeah what happens is nothing like
when you have when you have two more
pieces of fruit per day in a free living
situation you eat a little bit a little
less of something else and nothing
happens for the most part I mean I I did
a an experiment with my diet a while
back precisely around that like I I was
consuming no fruit because I was doing a
bunch of meal prep and all of my carbs
for the day were already accounted for
mostly from rice and also a larger
percentage that I'm comfortable with
from onions I really like onions but
sometimes I eat so many onions I smell
like onions and that's probably less
than ideal so I was like hey let's let's
just mix things around and let's get rid
of all other carb sources I'm just
eating chicken and fruit yeah and so
like
if that study was to be taken literally
like the the group that increased fruit
consumption gained like 15 pounds the
group that decreased fruit consumption
lost like 15 pounds yeah so and we're
talking about a difference in Fruit
servings of like two or three plus or
minus a day or potentially even less
yeah so I I went from zero servings of
fruit per day to
I don't know exactly how they Quantified
it in that study but probably like 25
servings of fruit per day and like it
was fine uh yeah on net it seemed to be
productive but uh
I just kind of got tired of of cutting
up all of that fruit and also like I
don't like going to the store that often
this was the biggest thing like fruit
goes bad and this this isn't food safety
advice audience they tell you like food
that you cook and then you put in the
fridge you should I think they say that
it's only like safe to eat for like four
or five days
that's a lie it's good for up to like a
week and a half
that I don't take that seriously I'm not
saying that as an expert that's not
advice to you me personally up to a week
and a half I'm like okay this is fine
whatever I've never gotten sick from it
yeah anyway fruit goes bad after like
three or four days so I I went from
going to the store once per seven to ten
days to go into the store like every two
days I was like ah this is just annoying
but in terms of body composition effects
it was entirely unremarkable yeah and if
if anything not not to give too much of
a spoiler there is some research kind of
hinting at the idea that when you add
fruit to your diet and you don't change
anything else and you're in a free
living situation you might even reduce
your caloric intake to offset that uh
you you might end up with a net
reduction in calorie intake if you
replaced kind of low satiety food
sources with fruit right so if you went
from like a sugary beverage to in to
increasing fruit intake adding that
fruit might actually induce just a tiny
bit of weight loss right so is that a
segue to the next section it is but uh I
have no idea how I'm going to address
editing those two things together that's
that's totally fine I can just put a
nice bow on my segment right here and we
can get into yours do it yeah so yeah
just to fully recap oh but wait I didn't
make the point I was trying to make the
point I was trying to make is again with
the people who were kind of sharing that
fruit study all over the place it's like
if the first thing they did was look at
the magnitude of weight change and just
ask themselves do you believe that
increasing your fruit by a couple
servings a day really is going to cause
you to gain 15 pounds and do you really
believe that reducing by a couple
servings a day is really going to cause
you to lose 15 pounds if all you did was
ask yourself that question you'd say no
and you'd shut your computer and walk
away yeah right but but it got all this
attention and no one bothered to ask
themselves do I believe this yeah yeah
but go ahead yeah so the the main point
I want to I want you to walk away with
is just in the context of this
particular study again title effective
resistance training mainly depends on
mechanical activation of fast twitch
fiber I am not arguing that that is
maybe even potentially not a true
statement who knows it could be the
point I'm making is that
you shouldn't rely on this citation to
make that point and if you see people
start to discuss this study start to
share it around maybe share this podcast
clip with them or if you do you know if
you uh aren't feeling uh generous and
wanting to give us the traffic uh just
ask them which they think would be
better for hypertrophy nine sets of 10
with a 30 RM load or three sets of 30.
and if they say oh it's got to be the
three sets of 30 say okay you don't
actually believe what this study is
saying
um and uh implore that they look at the
validation study it was based on and
asked them does the validation study
actually at any point measure fast
twitch fiber activation hopefully
they'll realize it doesn't and realize
uh maybe this isn't the study they
should rely on to make that point